mark german just came out with a new
bombshell report talking about apple's
september event that is happening in
less than one month and he revealed the
apple event date which is totally
unexpected to me because apple usually
hosts their september events on a
tuesday usually the second tuesday of
the month but no he gave us a date of
september 7th which is a wednesday and
he also gave us his reasoning for it
exactly what to expect at this event and
what not to expect because he talked
about some other leaks for other apple
devices coming later this year which i'm
also going to talk about so before i get
into all of those interesting details i
do want to quickly mention the different
devices that we should be expecting at
this september event happening on the
7th first of all we're getting the
iphone 14 lineup which is no longer
going to have a mini model and instead
of that mini we're going to be getting a
larger regular iphone 14 model with a
6.7 inch display for the first time
because you usually have to pay 1100
for the pro max model well not anymore
you're gonna be getting a cheaper iphone
14 plus or max for around 900. but what
i think is going to be really special
this year is actually the pro models
because they are getting some major
changes specifically finally getting rid
of that notch that has been around since
the iphone 10 yes we're moving to a dual
hole punch design with kind of a pill
shape and a hole next to each other and
that is gonna look sweet because it's
gonna allow apple to slam down the
bezels and make them look really nice
and thin and the way they're gonna be
able to do that is by slimming down the
speaker grill to like this razor thin
line at the top of the screen so it's
going to be barely noticeable and it's
going to look amazing now on the other
side we're going to be getting a new 48
megapixel camera that is capable of
shooting 8k video at 60 fps which i
think is going to be amazing this is
going to be the biggest iphone camera
revolution since probably ever this
would be a major difference in terms of
the actual camera quality and apple is
going to be doing it right this year
compared to a lot of the other android
brands that have 8k that looks worse
than apple's 4k and that's because
apple's gonna be building in 8k hevc
h.264 and pro res encoders and decoders
that are going to take the processing
load off of the actual chip itself and
just do that all on the media engine so
it's going to be super efficient and it
shouldn't heat up as much as a lot of
people are expecting so that's going to
be amazing then we also have
three new apple watch models yes all
three are gonna be new because they're
getting rid of the series three so
they're gonna have the apple watch se2
they're gonna have the regular series
eight and a brand new apple watch pro
model which i've made videos talking
about what to expect on that now the
interesting thing is that we just got a
report saying that apple is finally
moving some production of their macbook
and apple watch models over to vietnam
and that's because they want to
diversify their supply chain and have
less reliance on china because there's
some weird things going on there right
now and they're trying to get out of it
slowly so that's a good thing for them
and it means we could have less apple
watch shipping delays which is good for
all of us now mark also mentioned the
10th generation ipad but it seems like
he thinks it's coming later in the fall
which is weird because it usually comes
at apple's september event at least the
last three models that we've had and
specifically in a tweet that he just
posted he confirmed that yes the 10th
generation ipad is coming likely in
october so why the delay well first of
all apple has officially delayed ipad os
16 by about a month which means it's
probably coming in october and on top of
that this is going to be the first major
budget ipad redesigned in many years
with new flat sides apple pencil to
support and a usb type-c port so maybe
that's also why they could be delaying
this model by one month now moving on to
what we should expect interestingly he
didn't mention the airpods pro 2 at all
which is odd because i thought it could
be coming alongside the iphone lineup
because it should be getting upgraded to
bluetooth 5.2 with a new lc3 codec and
lossless support finally but maybe based
on mark's report maybe it's not gonna
come until later in the fall as well so
with that said i am super excited for
this event especially since it's
happening so early in the month so we're
gonna have iphone 14 models in our hands
on september 16th according to mark
german which is less than a month from
today that is amazing now as far as the
reasoning for the event happening on
wednesday the 7th instead of tuesday
mark german tweeted out that the reason
is because monday is labor day leaving
tuesday as a travel day which is why
they chose wednesday the 7th and also
apple did just change their employment
rules requiring employees to return to
the office three times per week starting
september 5th which seems to be a clue
for the event happening on the 7th now
moving on to the other things he
mentioned in his new article mark also
mentioned a couple of new products we
shouldn't expect until later in the fall
and some of these are quite surprising
first of all he believes the m2 ipad pro
models are coming later this year likely
in october which i agree with and those
are expected to come with new wireless
mac safe charging features now we also
mentioned a couple of macs that apple is
apparently looking to launch before the
end of the year including new versions
of the mac mini and high-end macbook
pros with m2 bass processors now this is
interesting because i personally
predicted that those new m2 pro and m2
max macbook pros would not come until
the spring of next year because i
believe apple is going to have a 1.5
year timeline for these macbook releases
especially since we just got the m2
macbook air one and a half years after
the m1 model and i also believe that
apple is going to hold off until the
spring because they want to build their
m2 pro and m2 max chips on tsmc's new
three nanometer process node instead of
the current n5p five nanometer process
node but when i spoke to mark german in
an exclusive interview he disagreed with
that theory and said it should be built
on five nanometer just like the m2
macbook air but honestly it's a really
tough call and he definitely has more
credibility and reputation than i do
but i'm still holding strong with my
thoughts on a spring event launch with
those high-end macbook pros on 3
nanometer instead of 5 nanometer now as
far as the mac mini mark said apple is
planning to launch it this year as well
and i totally agree i think it's
happening in october or november and
we're going to see the mac mini
regardless of whether it's gonna have a
redesign or not which mark thinks it's
not gonna have a redesign i'm still not
really sure about that point maybe apple
will just add some ports to the front of
the current design like the mac studio
who knows but either way we still have
some time to go for those new leaks to
flow in about those mac models but for
now we've got to focus on these awesome
new iphones and apple watches and other
products coming on september 7th so if
you're as excited as i am let me know
down in the comment section below and
click that circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
you